hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the Capablanca
saga it's the match that we've been
waiting for ho several Capablanca faces
serbian grandmaster Borislav Kostich a
match in cuba Havana and we covered a
lot of ground during the cup of Bunker
saga we covered his a match with the
Cuban national chip in one course or one
couple Blanco was 13 12 to 13 I believe
the match was held during capablanca
birthday Adam we went to his match with
Frank James marshaled into his first big
international tournament of San
Sebastian added into the big tournament
in sung Peter Berg then we covered a few
smaller tournaments a few simultaneous
exhibitions Adhan we covered the rice
Memorial Tournament in 1916 in New York
then at the 1918 tournament in New York
also that Capablanca won and
interestingly Capablanca faced boris of
course stage four times prior to this
match twice in the rice Memorial
Tournament in 1916 and twice in the New
York tournament of 1918 and although
okay some of the games were quick draws
but some of them were really exciting
draws like the one that we've covered
from the 1918 New York tournament but
all four games ended in a draw so it's
very interesting how this match will
turn out it's it's basically an eight
game match but not all eight games were
played you'll see why this happened and
well let's just enjoy enjoy the first
game so in the first game kappa blanka
had the white pieces and he opened with
e4 so let's see what happened in the
game Kosta to replied with E 5 with
Knight to f3 and the 9th to f6 so he
goes for the Petrov defense with Knight
captures on e5 d 6 pushing the knight
back Knight to f3 and now Knight
captures on e4 and queen to e2 this was
the most popular continuation in those
days Queen to e7 and now d3 pushing the
knight back Knight to f6 and the Bishop
to g5 and here costed she decides to
trade Queens with Queen captures Bishop
captures and now Bishop d7 both coupling
and Kostich are ready to castle with
Knight to c3 Bishop to d7 and now both
players just Castle with rook F to e 1
by kappa blanka and now
nice the seasick Scottish just
continuous development with d4 and now
rook F to e8 and it's interesting after
this game was played this position has
never occurred in tournament played ever
since
so Bishop to b5 by capablanca just you
know attacking the knight as the knight
is the one of the pieces that controlled
the center with a six bishop to a four
and now b5 Capablanca transfers the
bishop to this bigger diagonal but it
also allows Kostich this Knights to a5
move which frees his C pawn but also he
will be able to eliminate capital on his
light square Bishop whenever he pleases
and thus you know take away the bishop
pair from capablanca we have rook to e3
preparing rook a to e 1 cup of lanka
wants to double rooks and the e-file and
now c6 are taking away the d5 square
from a couple Blancas night here and now
rook 81 with King to FA by Kostich just
preparing bishop here so the King will
be helping out with the defense of the
rook here as Kostich is preparing Bishop
to the east to trade some rocks along
the e-file and here couple uncle plays
the very interesting Bishop to f4 which
pretty much saves him the bishop pair
because now they're it's a very tricky
position for example if you play a silly
move like h6 I already kappa blanka is
prepared to capture on e7 and after you
capture Bishop captures on d6 pins the
rook it's already attacked twice and
after you defended rook to e8 a couple
Blanca would just trade here and then go
95 and enjoy this position that is
better being a pawn up
of course he would enjoy that very much
so here you have to decide how to
prevent that one of the options is d5
but d5 still allows capablanca to go for
this route captures and e7 even though
it doesn't win a pawn but maybe it would
it maybe it would be a bit better for
Kostich as it leaves him the option of
at least eliminating the bishop whenever
he wants to but he doesn't really need
to as the pawns really create a nice
tool for this LightSquared Bishop Albert
okay Casta to decides to defend the
in a different way we have night the b7
guarding the d6 pawn and okay the game
continues with h3 Capablanca keeps a
special pair with h6 black also creates
some breathing room for Ace King and now
Bishop back to h2 with Bishop to d8 now
offering a trade of rooks kappa blanka
decides okay with rook captures Bishop
captures and now comes a for a nice
flank attack on the Queen side and
Kostich of course ignores this he goes
for c5 preparing c4 and capablanca finds
a nice idea to refute to this idea he
plays Knight to e4 now the main line
which of course we have to ask ourselves
what happens when black pushes c4
accosted you did not go for this but if
c4 capablanca is idea was a knight
captures on d6 and after C capture son
b3 Knight captures on b7 and now after
be captures and c2 now you can go
capture son b5 and if captures on b5
then you get captures captures and rook
the c1 and probably at some point even
if the pawn is defended you're gonna go
Knight e to win this pawn and Capablanca
would most likely go into this being a
pawn up so Kostich doesn't like this he
doesn't go c5 he finds a different idea
and Knight chapters on e4
but now capablanca doesn't capture
immediately because now c4 is actually
very strong so here kappa blanka found
an even better idea than recapturing
immediately so of course you see the
move maybe you want to pause the video
and find it but you know I'm pretty sure
you don't have to as you do see the move
the move is Bishop to d5 congratulations
as I know everyone saw it it attacks
this Knight it attacks this night so it
was a bit of a temporary peace sacrifice
but very soon you will recapture it so
what do you do here it's it's really a
tough position this Knight is under
attack and this Knight is under attack
and if both Knights move then nothing is
defending the d6 pawn so Bishop captures
and d6 will also be an idea this Knight
cannot move the rook is behind the night
so a very tricky position for example
one option is to play f5 give up the b7
Knight but here
after Bishop capture Sun b7 you will get
through k7 and now Bishop captures on e
4f captures on e4 and now Bishop
captures on d6 with chick there should
be seven you will capture with check and
after rook captures you will go Knight B
to go after this pawn C captures eight
captures you will get Bishop captures on
d5 and our rook captures on e4 and you
will get this position where a couple
Blanco has two point Islands Kostich s3
pawn islands and capablanca is up a pawn
so of course a better position for white
Kostich doesn't like this so he doesn't
go for a5 rather he goes rook to a7
defense the b7 it--and also gets his
rook out of this nasty diagonal with
Bishop captures on e4 and now Bishop to
e7 just defending this pawn here you
don't wanna love Bishop captures and
then you lose the pawn with a capture
some b-58 after Sun b 5d captures and c5
d captures and c5 and now an interesting
idea by kappa blanka rush up to b8
removing the defender of the night here
as the bishop attack is denied but it's
not a problem just locate you also
attack the bishop and here bishop back
to g3
so what's couple Blancas plan here i'm
sure cost each was very interested in
this as well so he just repeats rook to
a7 and Capablanca repeats again bishop
to b8 with rook to e8 and bishop back to
g3
Kostich repeats route to a 7 and now
capablanca doesn't repeat he goes nice
to e5 so basically what Capablanca did
with this Bishop b8 the g3 maneuver he
managed to get closer to time control
and also he improved his position the
bishop is no longer here but rather here
the position is exactly the same it's
just that this bishop is now in g3 which
creates some more breathing room for the
king and also the bishop is you know on
a better Square so he improves his
position without wasting time nice the
e5 by Capablanca with some ideas ongoing
knight c6 with an attack on the rook and
the bishop and here we have Knights to
d8 just getting this Knight other way
it's no longer a target and also you
guard the c6 square twice with b3
by Capablanca and now nights the e6 just
increasing the activity of this night
Bishop to d5 backup of Lanka and now
night the d4 going after the c2 pawn
so c3 pushing the knight back as the
bishop is guarding the b3 pawn and now
Knight to f5 again going after this
Bishop and here kappa blanka has to play
it back bishop to h2 so now was the
bishop to b8 followed by Bishop the g3
maneuver all that great it's hard to say
but cover Blanca did play it with b4 by
black and here capablanca before
deciding where to capture or to close up
the position on the Queen side first g4
pushes the knight back
Knight the d6 end only now c4 and here
something very interesting for us to see
here the pawns on the Queen side from
black are on dark squares and white
points are on light squares so if kappa
blanka
can somehow trade his light square
bishop for his opponent's light square
bishop that would be great because then
Kappa Blancas dark square bishop would
have targets whereas his opponent's dark
square bishop will not have targets as
kappa blanka spawns here are on lights
worse it's not much to go on but it is
something here by pushing c4 kappa
blanka also weakens the b3 point as now
it's a backwards undefended point Kosta
G goes for it rook to a3 cover Blanca of
course defends it looks to III and now
Knight to c8 just remembering the night
with Bishop to b7 attacking the knight
Knight to the a7 now with Bishop back to
d5 and here with f6 you don't want to
allow this pawn to remain a target with
some rook to f3 ideas so f6 first
pushing the knight back Knight to f3 and
now Knight back to c6 now the night is
nicely placed from there it can go here
it can go to a5 and serve as an
additional attacker to the b3 point and
here couple Blanca has to decide how is
he gonna defend the b3 pawn now you
don't want to capture the night here and
give up your bishop pair as I mean it's
very useful to have it in such a nice
endgame the place on both sides of the
board but also how do you defend the
the b3 porn it's a very nice idea here
kappa blanka did it by night to h4 so
how do you how to defend the B's report
we're playing Knight to h4 well the idea
is next here we have Knights to d4 now
the Knights can also attack the pawn
from here as the knight is no longer
guarding the d4 square but now Knights
the f5 attacking the knight attacking
the bishop here
the bishop is attacked twice so here you
kinda do have to trade with Knight
captures an f5 G captures an f5 and now
Bishop to d7 this point is under attack
so Bishop to e4 by capablanca everything
you know is in check and now look the a6
postage has to wait and see what
capablanca will do with rook to d3 and
now what do you play here here a
cross-stitch played Bishop to c6 but
there aren't all that many active moves
he can play and Capablanca was very
happy to enjoy this trade Bishop
captures rook captures and here King to
g2 capablanca starts bringing his King
into the game and here you can see that
he was successful like we mentioned he
was able to trade light square bishop so
now come on Kaz dark square Bishop has
targets here whereas hostage dark square
bishop does not have targets as long as
pawns on the Queen side are on light
squares so how will a couple Blanca go
about this first hostage goes to look to
a6 the beach every phone is still a weak
target so if at any point come on has
rook moves hostage is going to go after
it with King to f3 now going for some
increased activity with the King and
here rook to a2 Kostich does not allow
this King to move any further you have
to keep an eye on the f2 pawn but Bishop
to g3 just defending the pawn with King
- I ate a course which also wants to
increase the activity of obvious King
although it's not all that you know easy
easy to do and after Kostas played this
King t8 move it was in this position of
MU 55:51 that the game was adjourned
so I believe the game started at 2 p.m.
and lasted up until 8 p.m. so 6 hours of
play and then the games would be
continued the other day in the morning
so here it was in this position that the
game was adjourned so a constituent home
for Blanca went home
you know they each had their rest
analyzed the game analyzed the endgame
and of course came the next day prepared
or or did today we're gonna discuss this
a bit more but later
so here Capablanca played Bishop to F 4
in this position it's interesting if
Capablanca starts increasing the
activity of asking a bit too much less
the King e4 which seems like a very
natural move then you can get a rupee to
check and after King d5 seems like your
king is on such a nice square King D 7
and now you can no longer move your king
anywhere all of the squares for your
King are hard taken by by either black
pieces a black rook or the points and
it's very hard to this is to see how you
would make progress here
so capablanca was for a different plan
with Bishop to f4 and now look back to
a6 Casta she just has to wait and see
what couple long has plan is with Bishop
to e3 with some ideas of attacking the
c5 horn here and now route back to a1
with King to g4 back up Blanca and now
rook back to a7 King to h5 going after
g6 it would be a pretty big
accomplishment if capablanca managed to
get his king over to g6 now comes King
to f7 of course Kostich prevents this
we've looked at d5 now with a double
attack against the c5 pawn and here a
Kostich can go rook c7 but then both his
Bishop and rook are pretty much stuck
guarding the c5 pawn for the rest of the
game and the couple Monica will have all
the time in the world to improve his
position as much as he wants he can go
h5 King g4 he can put upon to h5 he can
start to bring his King into the game
move the rook somewhere play King d5 and
it's gonna be a lot of activity for
white with no moves to play for black so
here hostage decides to go for the
active defense
rook to a3 again going after the weak
pawn here kappa blanka here he has an
option he can go Bishop c5 or ruga d7
it's interesting couple blanca doesn't
like Bishop captures on c5 here you have
to capture the bishop because ruby d7
attacks the pinned piece it's it's all
over so here we would see a trade and if
if rook a person b3 rock c7 check King
e8 capablanca would get the the g6
square
the age for first not allow this pond to
remain the target then go g6 King
captures all rope captures and it seems
like a very promising position for a
kappa blanka but capablanca has a
different plan after ok 3 he goes rook
d7 first now threatens rook captures and
c5 but here Acosta just kicks it back
and the problem is of course you cannot
capture because if you capture Bishop
captures here you no longer have the e3
Square to defend your bishop here you
would just lose the game so a cost which
pushes the rug back King yet and now we
have looked back to d3 no again just cup
of lanka defends the b3 pawn king back
to f7 h4 and now rook the a7 cost is
rupees and here rook the d5 so what do
you play here now if Luke to a3 it's not
all that great if you play rook to a3
now it's a bit different because after
all I said and done there is no pawn on
h3 for black to target so here you would
just see the same variation only much
improved you know for kappa blanka
Bishop captures rook captures rook
captures here rook c7 check King to g8
or f8 King g6 and now there is no target
here so White's didn't have to waste a
move on moving the pawn and after Luke
f3 let's say going after the pawn h5 you
will capture the pawn here now Luke f7
check King gate you can capture here and
after black starts pushing his past pawn
you will just eliminate this pawn on the
next move you're gonna go for example B
to route b7 defend the queening square
here and you will be enjoying a winning
rook Rob King and rockin game so not all
that great now that Capablanca already
pushed the pond to h4 it's a minor
difference but it is a big difference
so rook to a5 just defending and here
cover Lanka creates a very nice
triangulation with rook to d7 again
not allowing the bishop to move not
allowing the rook to move due to Bishop
captures and c5 here of course it
repeats King e8 we have looked at b3
King back to f7 and now rook to d5 so
casablanca got to this exact same
position only now it's hostage to move
so what do you move here you can't move
the
otherwise you're gonna lose the pawn
here and we go into the line that we
explained it was winning for white if
you try and lose the move with Bishop to
f8 let's say then again rugby 7 check
King g8 you're gonna go King g6 and
again black isn't getting anything and a
couple of Lanka is just getting a much
better in better position so after Ruby
d5 Kostich decided to go into the the
line that isn't all that great for him
he played rook to a3 and now we get
Bishop Tadros on c5 but she captures the
line that we already shown rook captures
rook captures rook c7 check King to f8
and now King to g6 not having to worry
about the pawn sorry on h3 we have rook
to f3 by Kostich rook to f7 check King
t8 rook captures on g7 so everything
like we've shown now the differences
Luke to f4 goes after the c4 pawn with
h5 defending the h4 pawn and out rook
captures on c4 so Kostich now has a
passed pawn that he's ready to push but
Capablanca will also create one with
King captures and h6 now comes King to
f8 and now roped the b7 putting the
rogue behind the passport and now rook
to g4 with f3 by Capablanca trying to
pull this rook away from the defense of
the before pawn rook to g5 and now rook
captures on b4 and here a beautiful
beautiful idea why it's not okay to
capture the f5 pawn if caustics plays
rook captures on f5 then you get king g6
rook captures an f3 and now look the BH
check King the e7 and now comes h6 and
now after Luke the g3 check King to f5
look to h3 now the idea becomes clear of
course here the winning move is h7 and
there's no way to prevent the pond from
queening and of course if you capture it
rook b7 check wins the rook and of
course at the game so very interesting
how Capablanca knew this of course and
he said okay you cannot capture here you
should just either move your look or
play with the king
so Costas played King to f7 but now
comes look at the g4 couple Blanca
forces now black to either trade rooks
of course this will be
King and pawn and game for him sake
force forces him to capture the f5 pawn
now comes f4 and now rook to a5
Capablanca goes rook to g7 check King to
f8 and now rook to b7 and now the king
is ready to go up the board and the
pawns will also start marching forward
with f5 from Kostich and now King to g6
rook tsx check King captures an f5 there
was nothing better
rook to a5 with King to g4 now comes
Luke to a6 and now King to g5 Luke the
c6 now comes f5 from capablanca with
King to g8 and now f6r up the c8 with
rook to g7 check with King to f8 and
down h6 and it was in this position that
Borislav Kostich resigned the game as
there is nothing more to do here
whatever you play lightsaber rook c5
check you'll go king g6 and after Luke's
if c1 hoping for some checks you're
gonna get h7 robes you want check you
can go King h6 Rock h1 check and now
King g5 so here doesn't matter what you
do let's say Ruby 1 check King to f4 and
now you either capture but it isn't
enough because first white Queens here
you can go here and then it's gonna be a
quick game for white after this position
or after King to a4 instead of capturing
you can go rook to h1 but again just
rook g8 check and after the King moves
now you Queen the pawn and again nothing
to do here you will have to capture what
is upper rook and of course winning of
course did you knew all this so after
this King f8 and h6 he resigned the game
and a very impressive showing from
Borislav Kostich even though you know it
was pretty much Josh and game for the
gorge game for the entire game but a
little by little cup of Lanka was able
to create some chances get some sort of
a tubes one going on and in the end he
prevailed so first win ever by
capablanca over Borislav Kostich after 4
in incredible draws like we said - in
the 1969 between the 1918 tournament so
this is only first first game from this
match we're gonna check out all the
games from the match
I do hope you are going to enjoy them
because this is just a prelude to the
match with world champion Emanuel asked
her so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank my rich
yog and Vaman Rod Smith Melanie client
and the Leonel Manuel Tara's on her for
her contribution to my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos so
you are thinking for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the capablanca
saga checking up in your suggestions and
and so on thank you all I will see you
soon have an excellent rest of your day